cbs news has confirmed former michigan
governor rick snyder is expected to be
criminally charged
in the flint water crisis snyder who
left office two years ago would be the
highest ranking
public figure to be charged now this
case focuses on a decision that left the
city with lead contaminated
tap water believed to have caused a
legionnaire's disease outbreak
that killed at least 12 people adriana
diaz has covered this flint water crisis
since 2014
she looks now at the next step in this
case when the papers are in our hands
and we can see what the charges are what
the evidence is
then we'll believe it flint residents
like activist melissa mays say they've
been let down by the state
too many times to be anything but
skeptical
officials had been charged before but
the charges were dropped
after a new attorney general wanted to
re-examine the case
frustrating residents we demand
not ask for we demand that some criminal
charges be brought against
those that was a part of that the new
investigation led to these latest
charges
which could implicate former governor
rick snyder he was in office when state
appointed managers switched the city's
water supply
to save money but the water wasn't
treated properly
allowing lead to leech from pipes in a
scathing statement an attorney for the
former governor said the attorney
general's office
clearly needs a scapegoat after wasting
five years
on a fruitless investigation charges are
also expected against former public
works director howard croft his attorney
jamie white says he did nothing wrong
in order for everybody to lay their head
down on their pillow when this is said
and done
you know we have to give these
defendants a fair day in court
do these charges mean justice for you no
justice to us means being able to be
normal-ish to be able to trust
and know for a fact scientific fact that
the water coming through
my taps are safe
to this day flint residents still lined
up for bottled water
now most of the lead pipes leading into
people's homes have been checked for
safety
but many residents say they still have
damaged pipes inside their homes
as for these charges they haven't been
officially filed yet but cbs news has
learned
they're coming soon tony adriana thank
you i'm so glad we're sticking with that
story all these years later because the
repercussions are still around
thank you very much